the day after Therese may pulled the
vote on her brexit deal and the
atmosphere here in Westminster jumpy the
rumor mill in overdrive over whether a
confidence vote in the Prime Minister is
now coming after one false start last
month what I think has happened is with
the with the vote being Paul's
colleagues are now thinking well
actually this is the moment the Prime
Minister knew she couldn't present the
deal to Parliament so yes I think more
letters aren't well I know that more
letters are going in and it's a very
grave moment how confident are you it's
a very serious decision for every MP to
make both to put a letter in and to vote
no confidence in the Prime Minister so
it's very difficult to say but at the
moment I I think it's more than 50/50
likely that the Prime Minister will face
a vote and quite frankly rightly so at
the moment we have of course being here
before the er G's confidence in being
able to trigger this vote has to come
with a massive health warning just a few
weeks ago a number of them went over the
top only to find that their supporters
haven't fallen into line and when it
comes to the number of letters that have
been submitted only the keeper of the
lists so gray and Brady really knows but
one thing is certain the mood is
hardening against the PM mrs. Mays de
facto deputy defending her in the
Commons today as she made a desperate
dash to Europe trying to secure further
concessions to save her skin my right
honourable friend has spent more than 22
hours at this despatch box making
statements
and answering questions from right
honorable and honorable members in every
corner of this house but
parliamentarians furious she pulled the
vote as Labour called an emergency
debate to sock it to her I have never in
all those years witnessed such an abject
mess as this Prime Minister is making of
these crucial brexit negotiations
opposition MPs lining up to demand a
vote of no confidence in her government
will he not do the right thing no and
table a motion of no-confidence in this
government so we can be shot of them but
mr corbyn not biting for now today which
the member supported the tabling of we
have no confidence in this government we
need to do the appropriate thing at the
appropriate time to have a most of no
confidence in order to get rid of this
government mr corbyn clear today that
this is not the moment to call that vote
he'll only do it when he's confident he
can win the reports tonight the drg says
there are enough letters to trigger a no
confidence vote in your leadership have
you been told and if so what are you
going to do about it
know what I've been doing here in Europe
over the past day is actually doing what
I promised Parliament that I would do
which is to speak to other leaders in
Europe about the concerns Parliament
have raised about the backstop mrs. May
will return home tonight no respite
tomorrow though
she'll chair a cabinet who want to help
her but sources are already briefing
she'll be pushed hard on stepping up No
Deal preparations she's marching on but
events could still overtake her better
it be Sky News